well evictions are expected to increase
since the cove since the cdc moratorium
expired on saturday
uh help is available though for tenants
and landlords christian
that's right well one location for
in-person help is at the regional
justice center
in downtown las vegas the i-team's
vanessa murphy takes us there and has
more information
on guidance for tenants this is the
self-help center where tenants who have
received eviction notices can come for
help
and they're anticipating such a jump in
the number of people coming for help
that they've opened a second area we're
seeing a lot of tenants come in
really panicked about what it means that
the cdc moratorium is lifted
we're seeing a lot of tenants wonder
what that means for them
does that mean that they're going to get
locked out today does it mean they have
to wait for
their court hearing does it mean that
they have any additional protection
lauren pena is the directing attorney
here this is the first business day
since the cdc moratorium
on evictions expired saturday pena's
advice for tenants
don't ignore an eviction notice she
recommends filing an answer with the
court within seven
business days applying for rental
assistance and choosing mediation
if you don't file an answer you very
well may get locked down on that eighth
day
so to everybody who's getting a seven
day non-payment of rent notice or
any other kind of eviction notice there
are still protections
but you've got to file an answer with
the court and you've got to
apply for rental assistance legal aid
center of southern nevada
tells me in a typical month they help
about 3 200
tenants facing eviction issues in june
they report helping seven thousand
vanessa murphy eight news now now as you
heard their tenants can still file an
answer online or in person and there's
also help available by phone
we have all of that information for you
at 8newsnow.com